[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi and
welcome to episode number
34 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Model.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
good then, Francesc.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm very, very good.
I'm very happy and excited
about our guest today,
Aja Hammerly from our team.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yet another one of
our team members.
I always really enjoy
talking to our team members
because we have a great team.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's always fun.
We have very, very
different backgrounds,
and it's always fun to
talk to someone that you've
known a little bit enough.
And then all of a sudden she
starts telling you about, yeah,
fires in data centers.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
All sorts of fun stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It's very, very
interesting interview.
And at the end of this
interview-- actually,
maybe we should say what we're
going to be talking about.
We're going to be talking
about monitoring on the cloud,
and specifically Google Cloud
Platform using Stackdriver.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And after that we'll
have a question
of the week, which
is about data management across
the different [INAUDIBLE].
So what do you do if you have
some data in your machine,
some data in Google Cloud
Storage and some of it changes?
You want to update it, you
want to keep it synced,
what are the solutions?
MARK MANDEL: How do you do that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
But, before that, we
have the cool thing
of the week, which is
very, very cool today.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So the cool thing of the
week is that Kubernetes 1.3
was released.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
It is out and it is
already available
in the Kubernetes page,
and very, very soon on GKE.
MARK MANDEL: It's got
some really cool features
that have come a long way.
Kubernetes 1.3 has
some great stuff.
There is more work happening on
jobs and stuff that's already
in existence within Kubernetes.
But also we're seeing things
like cluster federation.
So being able to manage clusters
across regions of providers,
which is super,
super, super cool.
We're going to have a
link to a slide deck
that one of our team
members, extended
team members, Carter Morgan--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
call him a team member.
MARK MANDEL: Team member,
I think that's fair.
He's a super cool guy
and very, very smart,
and does a lot of
stuff with Kubernetes.
He has a slide deck that
covers some of the new features
in Kubernetes 1.3.
But yeah, as you said before,
it's available on GKE.
And when we say available,
it's rolling out
over the next week or so.
So if you've got
new projects, it's
probably going to
come to you maybe
a little sooner or maybe not.
But it'll get there.
It'll get there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
MARK MANDEL: It
will get there soon.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So we often talk
about like cool new things
and Kubernetes and things
like that.
But I think it's
important to remember
that if you're
interested in learning
the basics of Kubernetes.
This discourse on Udacity
with Carter Morgan and Kelsey
Hightower, which is
a great way to learn
the basics of Kubernetes
if you're crazy about it.
We'll have the show notes.
I will have the link
on the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So why don't we go and
have a chat with Aja.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm
very happy to welcome
Aja Hammerly from our team
to the Google Cloud Platform
Podcast.
Hey, Aja.
How are you doing?
AJA HAMMERLY: Hey, guys.
I'm doing great.
I'm really excited to be
on the podcast this week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We're very excited you're here.
Why don't you tell
us a bit about you.
We know you a
little bit already,
but our listeners don't.
Who are you?
AJA HAMMERLY: So
I'm Aja Hammerly.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Google Cloud team.
And I focus primarily on
monitoring, logging, trace,
debug-- all the things that
help you out when stuff
goes wrong on your website.
But before I came to Google I
had a large variety of jobs.
I was a developer,
I was a tester,
I was a release
manager at companies
that varied in size from a
really early stage startup
that I stayed with until
they got profitable or close
to profitable.
And I also worked at big
companies and little companies
as a contractor.
And so that's kind of
why I come and work
on the stuff dealing with
when things go wrong,
because I have been there.
I've held that pager.
I've had that midnight phone
call saying, wait, wait,
the site's down.
And I'm really passionate
about finding ways
that other people don't
get that phone call.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
such a good person.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
doesn't really sound fun.
So why don't you
tell us-- you say
that you are one of the
people on the team that
specializes in monitoring
and things like this.
What is monitoring?
AJA HAMMERLY: So I'm sure
that many of your listeners
have been there where
they've got a website
or they've got some
sort of cloud-based
or even locally-based
application that's spreading.
And they need to know
when bad things happen.
Because we all know that
computers are not actually
perfect all the time.
Disks go bad, disks fill up.
We as software
developers write bugs.
I have certainly
written my fair share.
And we need to know
when that stuff is
happening because it has the
ability to take down our site.
And pretty much anyone
doesn't want their site
to go down without them at
least knowing ahead of time
and preferably them
doing it on purpose.
Because sites that
go down our workloads
that stop running
usually mean lost money.
And monitoring is
the way that we
keep track of how the resources,
how the application is
behaving, so we can have
a high-level picture
that everything is OK.
A lot of the places
I've worked have
had some sort of
monitoring dashboard
that's mounted up on a screen
that's visible to everyone,
so that everyone can kind of
have a high-level picture that,
yes, everything is OK, and
that things are going well.
Or no, everything isn't.
You can see the
trends and you can
deal with it before something
actually takes the site down.
And monitoring is
also the kind of thing
that, if you're one
of those people who
used to carry a pager or
still carries a pager,
or your team passes
around an on-call phone
or maybe you've upgraded
to the current decade
and you have a system that
changes who's on call and just
calls your personal phone,
those kinds of alerts
are also triggered
by monitoring.
Hopefully those alerts happen
when something is bad enough
that it needs urgent attention.
But hopefully not bad enough
that the site is already down.
And I have been there.
And I have carried that pager.
And I actually still have kind
of a negative visceral reaction
to a specific ring tone for
a specific brand of phone,
because that was the sound
that our on-call phone made.
And it always meant that
whatever I was doing
was going to have
to be put aside.
So like, if I was out
to dinner with people,
I was going to have to sit
there, pull out the laptop
and, you know, reboot servers
from the dinner table.
And I've done it.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
Yep.
MARK MANDEL: I have
similar visceral reactions
to certain noises.
So that's really cool.
I think it's worth making
the point that monitoring,
it's both preventive as
well as incident-based.
Would that be a fair summation?
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
It is both.
In my world, I
would really like it
to be more preventative
than incident-based
but computers are computers.
And I've been on the
on-call team or the ops team
through two data
center fires now.
So sometimes you just
can't be preventative.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Out of curiosity,
when you say a data center
fire, is it a literal fire?
AJA HAMMERLY: Yes.
Both of them.
One company that I worked
at, our data center,
the auxiliary power
units caught fire.
The whole data center went down.
And they actually
emailed-- when they finally
got some of the stuff back up
they emailed all the people who
were hosted there a picture
of the charred auxiliary power
unit that had taken down a
good hunk of the data center.
And then the other
data center fire
we dealt with there was
actually at one of our vendors.
And it was over a
holiday weekend.
And so the fire department
got the fire out,
but they couldn't actually
go back in and certify
that they could turn
the electricity back
on to the data center until
after the holiday weekend.
So one of our vendors
was entirely down
for a four-day weekend
or three-day weekend.
MARK MANDEL: Fun.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
monitoring will detect that.
I'm assuming it will.
[LAUGHING]
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
It detects if
resources go completely
away pretty effectively.
Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
But what is the kind of
things that you monitor?
I understand that you monitor
the [INAUDIBLE] machine
and maybe you monitor if
a network is up or not.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Do you
monitor other things?
AJA HAMMERLY: So
I think about it--
if you've been around
for a while, are
you familiar with networking?
They talk about
layers of networking.
And I actually think about
things as layers of monitoring.
So at the base layer,
I monitor to make sure
that the resources that I
expect to be up in terms of VMs
or physical machines are up.
They are on, or
they are responding
to just low-level ping.
I also monitor things like
CPU usage, memory usage,
and disk usage.
Disk usage is one
that has burned me
enough times that I always
keep a really good eye on it.
Because if you end up
with a bug that ends up
spewing a bunch of
stuff to your logs,
you can actually
fill up your disk.
And the applications
I generally work
with have been Rails and Node,
and neither of those deals too
well with not being able
to write logs at all.
So I monitor CPU disk
usage memory usage.
And I'm mostly
monitoring those things
to make sure that they
stay about the same.
Because if they
start doing something
that looks outside of what
looks normal for them,
it's usually an indication
that I have a software
bug that I haven't detected.
And then after the basic level
of monitoring system resources,
sometimes I'll monitor
load balancers and network
connections as well.
I then start monitoring stuff
in the application layer.
And that's going
to really depend
on what your application is.
Because if you've got
an app that's primarily
doing video
transcoding, the things
that you're interested in are
very different than the things
that someone who's got a
web serving workload is.
A web serving
workload, they might
be interested in the number
of 400 and 500 range errors
that they get.
Or they might be
interested in latency.
Or they might be interested that
a certain endpoint is getting
most of the traffic,
or a certain endpoint
is getting a normal
amount of traffic.
Because they want
to know if there's
a problem in their
application logic or pipeline.
And so it really
depends on the workload,
what I end up monitoring.
But I do try to
monitor out all layers.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So let's talk about
what monitoring
is available on
Google Cloud Platform.
We have this stuff
called Stackdriver.
I believe that used to
be a different company?
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
Stackdriver was
acquired by Google.
And they've been working
to integrate their products
seamlessly into the existing
Google Cloud Platform Console.
And the integration is
lovely at this point.
I've really enjoyed--
as someone who's
used a lot of different
monitoring tools
over the years, how the
place where I create my VMs
is the same place that
I can see my alerts.
I can see a dashboard.
It's the same place
that I can see my logs.
It's the same place that I can
see error reports distilled.
It's all one login.
And when I go talk to
folks about their Ops stack
or their monitoring
stack, most folks
seem to have four or
five products now.
One of the things I
love about Stackdriver
is that it's one
product that does
all the things with one login.
So figuring out who
needs permissions
for what is actually
really straightforward.
When you get a new
employee, you don't
have to give them an account
to five different services.
And specifically on
the monitoring side,
Stackdriver monitors all of
our Google Cloud Platform
Resources.
It can monitor App Engine, it
can monitor Compute Engine.
It monitors Load Balancers.
And they can also
monitor resources
that are in AWS as well.
It's cross-cloud.
There's been a lot of
push in the industry
and also some
internally at Google
that many of our products
now work across cloud.
Another good example
of that is Kubernetes,
which works cross-cloud.
And Kubernetes is not
technically Google's product.
It's an open source product.
But it's another example of
how Google is really pushing
for the cross-cloud support.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So we could probably go
through all of the Stackdriver
features for hours
and hours on end,
but since we only have
about 20 or 30 minutes,
do you want to give us some
of your favorite features
of the Stackdriver monitoring?
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
So I'm going to kind
of go-- depending
on what resources
you're monitoring,
I have different
favorite features.
So one of my favorite features
is for App Engine actually,
and that latency
monitoring is built in.
I can say, I would like
to monitor latency.
And I would like
to get alerted when
latency is over this threshold
or increases by this much.
And the other
thing I really like
about the latency monitoring
for App Engine that's built in
is that you can monitor at 95%.
So you can say, I want
95% of my requests
to be at least this fast.
You can monitor at the 5%.
You can say, so if 5% of my
requests are slower than this,
that's an alert.
Or you can look at the average.
And several of the apps
that I've worked on
have had an endpoint
that is like really
fast most of the
time-- under 100
milliseconds most of the time.
But occasionally
there's that edge case
through the code that's
just going to take forever.
And you know it's
going to take forever
but it really drags
down your averages.
So the fact that I can
make those outliers go away
on my monitoring is
wonderful, because that
means that I don't get
that page if we happen
to get some anomalous
traffic and get
a couple of extra things to
the bad path a couple times.
And sometimes, you know,
you want to fix that path.
But sometimes you look at
it and you're like, yeah
that happens 1,000 times a day.
I don't care.
It's not worth the
dev effort to fix it.
So that's one of my
favorite features
in App Engine is monitoring,
or Stackdriver for App Engine
is the latency monitoring.
And then you can not
go into Compute Engine.
And one of the things I
like about Stackdriver
with computer engine.
And I actually didn't know
this until I was setting up
a demo recently is that
there's built in monitoring
for a bunch of different common
tools like MySQL or Cassandra
or RabbitMQ.
And sometimes the story
is a little bit weird.
I recommend folks
go look at the docs.
We will actually detect that
you're running MySQL on a given
computer engine instance.
And we do that by looking
at this instance name,
looking at the processes
that are running,
and also looking at
what ports are open.
And we can turn on the
monitoring for MySQL
automatically.
So we'll say, oh, you're
running a MySQL instance
on this computer engine.
And the MySQL metrics
will magically
be available in your
Stackdriver dashboard.
And I hate to use magic
because it's all computers.
It's all done with
well-written code.
But you know, any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic.
It was a lovely surprise when I
was setting up a MySQL Cluster.
And even if it isn't
automatically detected,
turning it on is super easy.
You add a config file and
you restart the Stackdriver
monitoring process.
And now you have access
to metrics such as inserts
and updates for MySQL.
For Engine X you have access
to the HTTP connections,
how many are waiting.
That kind of thing.
The metrics that make sense are
available when you need them,
but they're not crowding
your dashboard out
when they don't
actually make sense.
And so that intelligent
decision about which
metrics to make available
is really, really nice.
MARK MANDEL: That's really cool.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
The other thing that
I like is that there's
monitoring in for Google
Container Engine as well.
So if you're running a
Container Engine cluster,
there's a dashboard
that you get just by--
and this is in the free tier.
You can just go to
Stackdriver and you
can see monitoring of your
Container Engine resources,
both by containers and
also by the underlying VMs.
And that's awesome.
MARK MANDEL: So it sounds
like there is a bunch of stuff
that's like out of
the box, ready to go.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: As long as you're
using some cloud product
on Google Cloud Platform.
We're just like,
yeah, here you go.
Is there anywhere where you
have to do manual steps?
I think on GCE you have
to install an agent?
Is that right?
AJA HAMMERLY: Depending
on how you started it up,
you may have to
install the agent.
You do have to install
the agent in AWS
if you're going to use it there.
When I did it for
a recent demo, it
took me less than five minutes.
The instructions
are super clear.
And if you're one of the
people like most of the folks
I hang out with in the
Dev-Ops community who
uses something like
Ansible or Chef
or Puppet to provision
your VMs, you
can actually install the agent
in a very straightforward way
with those tools.
There's a cookbook for
it, for Chef for example.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
AJA HAMMERLY: And
so if you don't
want to do it by hand, doing it
automatically is really easy.
And it's just another
monitoring agent.
I've used many, many
monitoring services,
and they all pretty much
have this requirement.
But it doesn't take long.
You curl down some code.
You put it in a directory
and change the permissions
and start it up.
It's really
straightforward if you're
in a world where you do
that kind of thing often.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So it seems like having
the basic monitoring
of your application, regardless
of the stack that you're using
is pretty easy.
What if you want to have some
specific metric that only
your application knows about?
How does Stackdriver
handle those cases?
AJA HAMMERLY: So you
can do custom metrics.
And that's one of the
things that I really like.
Because when I've
done apps before,
we frequently would sit down.
We're like, we'll how do
we know if everything's OK?
And we would sit
down over a table
and come up with a decision
that these five end
points need to respond in
less than 100 milliseconds 95%
of the time.
And then we would then-- with
Stackdriver you could then
build up a metric for that.
Or I worked on
another app where we
did a bunch of image
resizing as part of the load.
And so we needed to know
how well the memories
it was on the machine.
And we had a bar where
if the memories, which
went beyond a
certain amount, that
was concerning because we had
messed up the image resizing
process.
And with Stackdriver you
can create custom metrics.
And you can also create custom
metrics that you actually
report from your application.
There's an API
that you can report
in the Stackdriver, a metric
that is interesting to you,
and have that show
up in your dashboard
and get alerts based on
that, which is awesome.
And all those are going
to be app-specific.
That's one of the things that's
really hard about talking
about the cloud is there's so
much that you can do with it.
And everyone's workload is
just slightly different.
I know a lot about
web serving workloads.
But there are so
many cool things
that people are doing
that aren't specifically
web serving.
Data processing, for example.
There might be other metrics
that you need to report in on.
And that's something that you
could do with custom metrics
as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So right now if people want
to get a using of Stackdriver,
it's in beta so
it's currently free.
But there was a
recent announcement
for what the pricing
structure is.
Do you want to talk a
little bit about that?
It seems pretty
straightforward though.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
So the basic pricing
structure, when it goes out
of beta and into
general availability
is there's going
to be a free tier.
And that's going to provide
you access to metrics
traces and error reports.
Because we're
talking specifically
today about monitoring.
But Stackdriver is a
much bigger product than.
That there's a lot of
other features involved.
And those are all going be
available in your Google Cloud
Platform dashboard.
And you can get that free
monitoring on Google Cloud
Platform resources.
So if you're using App Engine,
if you're using Compute Engine,
you'll be able to see
your metrics in real-time
on the dashboard for free.
Now we're going
have a premium tier.
That will give you your Amazon
Web Services integrations.
There's your cross-cloud.
It's also going to give you
support, if you need support
on your monitoring logging.
If you want to
get alerts, so you
want to be notified in Slack or
HipChat or PagerDuty or by SMS,
all that's going to be a
part of the premium tier.
It also gives you custom metrics
and several other features.
So the premium tier is priced
at $8 per monitored resource
per month.
And that's prorated hourly.
And that's kind of the basics.
So $8 a month per
monitored resource.
Now the question everyone
asks is-- there's two of them.
What the heck is a
monitored resource?
And the second question
is, how does that
work if you're auto-scaling?
So monitor resources are
App Engine instances,
compute engine instances,
cloud SQL, and load balancers.
So basically everything
that can be mapped to a VM
is going to be an instance.
So when you scale up
your App Engine app
you have more VMs
that are provisioned.
And then you scale it back down.
And then the auto
scaling is, they're going
to take a snapshot every hour.
And they're going to figure out
how many monitored resources
you're using every hour.
And they're going to
prorate based on that.
So if you spin up a VM
and then spin it back down
or you use a bunch of
different VMs over the month,
we're going to try
to come up with a way
to smash those
together, bin pack them,
to give you the pricing.
So you don't have to worry
about us charging you
for every single different
instance that you spin up.
So it should work in a logical
way for auto scaling groups.
You should pay for a
fraction of that $8
for the fraction of the
time that you're scaled up.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
So if I'm on App Engine standard
and I have a short spike where
it goes up a fair bit, but
then comes back down relatively
quickly, it sort of mushes that
all together into one big chunk
that I don't have to
worry about too much.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
And it's prorated hourly.
So divide $8 by the number of
hours in the month and that's
your hourly rate.
It's really not
that much at all.
The other question
people ask is about how
that works for containers.
If you're running containers
on Compute Engine,
and if you're using
Container Engine,
you are actually
running a containers
on computer engine resources.
We're still just
going to charge you
for the computer engine VMs and
the amount of time they're up.
So if you scale
up your containers
but you don't actually
scale up the number of hosts
that you're using
to run them, you're
still going to be
paying the same price.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: That's very cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're
kind of running out of time,
but there's actually a question
that I would like to ask you.
Which is, OK so I did not
know monitoring was a thing.
And I have something
running in production.
What do I do?
What is the first thing I should
start doing, like right now?
AJA HAMMERLY: So
here's the thing
that I tell folks what
I'm doing mentoring,
and I will say right now that
I am not an expert on dev ops.
But the very first
thing you do is
you should set up
an uptime monitor.
And all that's
going to do is it's
going to-- I usually
set this up to hit
a specific URL frequently,
the base page of my app.
And it tells me if that
page stops responding.
So it basically tells
you if that page
is throwing a 500 or 404.
If I want to get a little more
sophisticated in Stackdriver,
you can do this.
You can have it check for
a specific string a texts.
And I often do the company name
in the footer, because almost
everyone has their company
name, and the copyright info
or their name and
the copyright info
in the footer of their website.
And if that stop
showing up, you know
that there's a problem with
basic rendering of your page.
Pro tip, don't use the date
if your date auto increments
on the new year, because then
you get a new year's day page
when the date auto increments.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Happy new year.
AJA HAMMERLY: But get your
up time monitor setup.
And then the next thing
I think folks should do,
is they should set up some sort
of metrics based on latency
or application
errors on the things
that they know cause a bad
time for their customers.
And they should also set
up some basic metrics.
With Stackdriver you can
do it based on trend.
So if your memory
usage increases
by 200% over 10 minutes,
that's the kind of alert
I would set up on
the system level.
Because that means you
don't have to actually know
what your normal state is.
But you can still get an alert
if something weird starts
happening.
Because the whole goal
of monitoring is to let
you know that something
weird is happening,
so that then you can use
your big human brain to try
to figure out what it is.
MARK MANDEL: So really
it's about change.
It's not necessarily
what your base case is.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
That's the, I have no
idea about monitoring
and I would like
to get in, I would
like to do this thing
because it sounds good story.
It's focus on change
and focus on making sure
that the basics of
your site are up.
Because the worst
thing that can happen
is someone types in your URL
or clicks a link in search
results and ends up
at a 400 or a 500.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that makes sense.
All right, Before we finish up,
is there anything in particular
that you'd want to mention
or feature or highlight,
or anything fun like
that we may have missed?
AJA HAMMERLY: No,
I don't think so.
I just think everyone should
at least-- since it's free
right now, people should
check out Stackdriver, try it.
If they've got a
cross cloud load
they should totally
try it there and they
can see how awesome
it is to have
their AWS on their
GCP resources side
by side in their dashboard.
The example I did for
one of the talks I gave
recently was I did in MySQL
Cluster that was half in GCP
and half in AWS.
And I was replicating
from JCP to AWS.
And it was really great to
see the compute resources that
were being used, memory
disk and all that.
But also seeing the
inserts and the deletes
and the updates side by
side for all of them.
And I was able to set
up the same alerts
on the same exact
thresholds for both clouds.
And seeing that side
by side as someone
who's done a
combination of cloud
and on prem, as
someone who's done
cross cloud as part of
disaster recovery and all
that, it was really nice.
And it made me wish I
had these features back
when I was responsible
for keeping a site up.
So I think people, while it's
in beta should go check it out.
See if it's going
to work for them.
See what it looks like
when all of your monitoring
logging, error reporting stuff
is all in the same place.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I
think that the demo that you
were mentioning-- not only
you gave the talk but you
also wrote a blog post?
AJA HAMMERLY: I did.
There's a blog post on the
GCP blog called, Six Things
Stackdriver Brings
to the Dev-Ops Table.
And it's awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we'll add that to
the show notes for sure.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
All right, great.
Thank you so much
for joining us, Aja.
It was great talking to you.
I learned a whole
bunch about monitoring
I didn't know before.
AJA HAMMERLY: Thanks, guys.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
This was really, really fun.
MARK MANDEL: That was
a great conversation
that we had with Aja.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
I learned a whole
lot about what's
possible and not possible
with our monitoring solutions.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Finally you can detect if
your data center is on fire.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I think I want to set up custom
metrics with smoke detectors
so that they can send
it to Stackdriver,
and then they'll be like,
yes, there's a fire.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There
is indeed a fire.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
An uptime check is not enough.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah.
Resetting the computer
will not fix the fire.
MARK MANDEL: No.
No.
Absolutely.
All right.
So why don't we get on
to question of the week.
I think you had an
interesting one there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Why don't
I set it up for you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
MARK MANDEL: You can
give me the answer.
So we were talking
about if, say,
you've got a Google
Cloud storage bucket
and there's a bunch
of data in it.
And you're like, OK, I
want to pull this data down
so I can look at it.
So you pull it
down using gsutil.
Great, that's fine.
And then you're like,
oh wait, there's
some stuff I need
to change in it.
So I make some small changes
to maybe three or four
out of the 200 files
or something like that.
But I want to sync that
up to what's in the cloud.
But I'd rather not send all
that data straight back up.
I'd rather just do
whatever's changed.
Is there a way I can do that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Absolutely.
And the way I see it is, not
everybody knows this command
because it's a Linux command.
And it is actually
not that well known.
MARK MANDEL: Really?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I mean, you have a Linux laptop.
But not everybody does.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, but there's
this command called R-sync.
Basically what it
will do is it will
check the difference between
the contents of the source
and the content of
the destination.
And it will send
only the changes.
And not only that, but it will
also the checksums to make sure
that everything that
you're actually sending
will be correctly received.
So basically it's
a very safe way
of syncing back your changes
to the original data store.
Now, it is important
to be careful.
Because there's one thing
which is like the dash.
So dash D. In dash
D what it will do
is will do it recursively.
And I've done this.
You know the commands have
source and destination.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And source
goes first and destination
goes after.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, you
don't want to flip those.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If you flip
those, basically what you do--
yeah, you delete all your data.
So you should be
careful with that.
MARK MANDEL: So dash
D does the delete?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No.
Dash D, what it does
is basically recursive.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So like Directory.
So if you say, oh, I
want to change everything
that is inside of this
place with-- like,
this is the source
that's the destination
and you do it backwards?
Yeah, that's bad times.
So you don't want to do that.
And if you want to understand
better what Our Sync does.
For me the way I see it
is kind of like, get.
When you do get and
you don't get pull,
get push, what
you're sending over
the network is just the
difference between the files.
That's exactly what we're doing.
So if you have a huge data file.
Let's say like 1
gigabyte, and you only
change the first 1k of
that image-- probably it's
a image or video.
Whatever.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You will only
send that part of the change.
So it will be much, much faster
than sending the whole file
back up.
MARK MANDEL: So for those people
who are familiar with Our Sync,
is this just using Our Sync?
Or is this Our Sync
with some G Cloud tools?
How does that work?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So Our Sync is Linux
command as we were saying.
You could I guess
use Our Sync directly
with Google Cloud Storage.
But you're going to have to be
dealing with authentication.
And I'm not really
sure it could work.
So instead we have
gsutil, Our Sync,
which is a
sub-command of gsutil.
So you can simply say, gsutil,
Our Sync, source directory,
which could be either your
local machine or somewhere
in the cloud-- eventually
Google Cloud Storage.
But actually you can do
it over multiple clouds.
And then a destination
which, again could be either
local or something remote.
And it will just do
the same between.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
Actually I'm just looking.
You can also do it from between
like Google Cloud Storage
and like an S3 bucket as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, absolutely.
So that is pretty cool
if you're thinking
about migrating or having
two different things that
are up to date.
You could run these regularly.
Like every day at some times
you just run this script
and it just updates
everything together.
So it's a very, very handy tool
if you need to sync things up,
Our Sync is what you want.
MARK MANDEL: That
sounds very good.
Excellent.
Well, thank you very much
for joining us this week.
I believe when this
comes out, you'll
be doing something special?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So, last episode-- I don't
know how to use calendars.
MARK MANDEL: Time is just
very, very difficult.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it's not even time zone.
It's weeks.
So yeah-- well not wigs, weeks.
Yeah.
By the time this
episode comes out,
I will actually be at GopherCon.
I'm doing the opening keynote
and am super excited about it.
My slides are-- they're
starting to look good.
I think that it's going
to be a good time.
MARK MANDEL: I've seen some
rehearsals-- pretty impressed.
Just want to say, just
a little bit impressed.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
pretty excited about that.
So yeah, I will still
be in GopherCon.
And actually on Wednesday we'll
be running Go Project room.
So if you're wrong go there.
Go check it out.
We're going to be talking
about the Go Project.
We even have a little
session on diversity.
We're going to be
discussing, what can
we do to make the Go
community more welcoming.
So if you want to go
say hi, come say hi.
MARK MANDEL: Head on down.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And what about you?
MARK MANDEL: So unfortunately
I won't be at GopherCon.
It doesn't pan out
for me this year.
I think for me next will
be, in August I will
be at PAX Dev in some capacity.
So if you're going to be there,
drop me a line on Twitter
or something like
that and let me know.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: In August.
Oh my god, you're not doing
anything until August.
MARK MANDEL: I have
some things cooking.
Nothing's been sort
of locked down yet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We will announce.
MARK MANDEL: We'll work it out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
Well, thank you so much
again for taking the time
to do this episode.
I really enjoyed this one.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Me too.
Thank you so much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
see you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.